hey everyone welcome back to another
week of top 5 scary mods of the week
with your hosts cam and said Oh finally
we're on level pegging you've earned it
so exacting you over yes yes over 50
episodes but I finally referred to you
as a host which I should we do this long
does this mean we get to call each other
friends now oh come on whatever the time
but yeah so today although although we
are actually recording ahead of time
this week because Seb we're going to the
holiday oh yeah we are we are we're
going on holiday together
yeah it's but Brendan's not just us
though there will be other friends there
too we'll see if your friends statist by
the end that's it I won't find out we'll
find out but said we are returning to
normality this week because of course
last week we showed off we delved into
the world of oblivion and Morrowind hmm
boy was it fun and I'm blocky and maybe
loading so well in the distance by oh
man was it a trip down memory lane
sure was so this week we are back to
normal we have five great mods so let's
get to mod number one
sad we're back in Skyrim for mod number
one and if i zoom out to third person
and pan the camera around we can see it
and it's filled glory oh there's our
dashing hero but what's he wearing
well he's wearing Dark Souls combined
set one chorus nice and isn't he look
glorious nesib are you a big Dark Souls
player uh no neither mine neither mine
that's okay I sorry I don't know if
you're expecting a better answer than I
don't know my answer is No however our
good friend and colleague Martin Gaston
is a huge way and he's gonna get very
excited you should really be here yeah
why is it us Martin get in here so the
end in a while but this one was
recommended to us by a Ryan duck dial
dial that's your name now
yeah and it's a it's actually neither
from the Nexus or from the workshop it's
from the lovers lab the lovers lab be
where the lovers labs they're the lovers
lab because the lovers lab features so
I'm not entirely safe for work bits and
pieces
it sure does but man this armor is
definitely safe or will keep Kevin
Bernard safe oh yeah something like that
some sort of link so this is the this is
the Knights armor yeah but there's
multiple variations you get as part of
the mod so here we have the elite Knight
armor ah this is really cool I really
like this as a detail the attention to
details fantastic
and this EMB Solaris so what it's called
no this is sarin ours are incised made
one up Solaris CMV someone make it right
now yeah it's gonna be the Sun
everything's yellow that's the crest
shield they're not oh man
I like that a lot did you jump well in
it you know it keeps you nimble wow he
really jumps high he's getting bad no of
course he did why I suspect well I just
forgot cuz I can see his face oh my
goodness that's pretty grim what is
going on here this always a shield
yes so this is the notorious armor I
think all right
I can't quite work out what's going on
with the face don't necessarily need a
face yeah yeah would you like this kid
yeah she I should call get over the
shield yeah it's like holding up a piece
of wall oh wow it looks your entire view
in combat that's that's good it just
means your face is protect oh yeah I
mean you can see that little of you can
survey the world through that little bit
of it's also thanks to our M depth of
field mode everything's a blur it out of
there's a man that's awesome well said
this is the Great Lord armor set it's
pretty great I tell you what the
greatest bit is that crown is phenomenal
look at that it looks so pleased with
himself heaven really suits crowns you
know I don't know why I'm surprised and
like I like the feathers the feathers in
the shoulders
real nice guy even noise that yeah look
at those feathers this whoops that's his
call sighs such detail such detail any
of the or Stein's one where you gives
you the face of a weird dog thing that's
real way this is pretty terrifying I'm
gonna say some of this some of this
stuff is quite quite quite scary like it
you know I don't understand you know a
lot about the physics of a head inside
of a helmet but that looks like it's
kind of crushed his forehead oh yeah you
know like there's not much room for a
head in there right now I feel like
somewhere in there that helmet is not
crazy comfortable no I think that must I
think is slowly killing him so that's
pretty much everything in the pack but
we've also got an this gold tracer which
is like this amazing glowing dagger
thing in fact that every one of the
armors has its accompanying swords yeah
yeah but I think we'll need to show off
the swords in mod number two absolutely
let's get to it
okay time for mod number two which this
week is the user voted mod said what is
it yeah we usually do this last but this
one's too cool so this is why why and
replacer mystic night now you might have
noticed earlier even when we were
standing showing off the Dark Souls
armor that Kevin has adopted a new
standing position so basically this mod
adds a whole load of new animations
right yeah so it's changed everything to
do with one-handed combat and magic so
it's it's not really gonna have affected
great sword stuff but you will notice
that the poses are different animations
are different and even if you were to
put that sword away the best one
oh let's show that off again listen for
the noise oh man really sweet so for
example now when Kevin's holding a flame
spell in his left hand he's got a sword
in the right and he's got this cool
little sort of like love that holding it
ready to go to anything as poised even
lighting up his is clothes that's
amazing right so this is oak flesh yeah
this is a buff spell all buff spells
should look like this all right it's
very fragrant he holds it up in front of
him yeah I clicks it out the side to do
more of I suppose like a dance move you
see more with just just up here but nary
like yeah yeah that's cool Oh oh wow
well we are practicing magic happen uh
maybe some other time sorry pal no let's
let's get away from that girion bugger
off we're practicing wards yeah yeah
time for this week's Cooper's impressing
words so this is his new crouching pose
you know it's uh instead of just being
down on his two feet he's actually down
on one knee yeah it makes a lot more
sense because otherwise you get so tired
have you tried to like maintain a
crouching kind of half squat pose no
this is much more much more realistic I
guess yeah it looks epic yeah even the
way he hill sort of move around from
that is that is different as well so I
got this new running animation stabbed
as well with two swords and let's use
that to charge down these bandits oh it
looks real cool the other thing that
they've done as well is that especially
for folks who are nice kill me folks who
like to play with cloaks
they've removed a cloak clipping where
your grapples will run
through the cloak behind you you know
yeah yeah that was always slightly
off-putting when you see that man this
arm is getting covered in blood they're
all very subtle I feel like what they've
gone for is kind of like an anime yes
I'll look right yeah exactly which is
which is why it almost works with the
you know darks with dog so it's not
anime game but it's like I know it's
Namco Bandai right so it kind of fits so
serve the master spells have a
completely new animation which is epic
but let's use it to do some damage to
some more bandits all right let's give
this a go uh-oh oh we're gonna be those
guys oh man it was epic oh that's been
right they're still alive
although man they are sages and rightly
so they are terrified of that are you
fully levitating off the ground yeah
what's it look like a first person that
wanders tries no that's the original so
yeah first person you get the original
animation yeah wow that's awesome
where did you come from let's finish him
off don't like that avoid some
one-handed combat yeah and then come
away go cooler there my word look at his
armor somehow none on the face oh yeah
beautifully shown he's an artist if
nothing else okeydoke time for mod
number three which is unique dragon
priest mask HD textures and we've gone
for the replacer version so we've
replaced all the standard dragon priest
masks with new ones yeah so this one's
the this is the wooden mask yeah it
looks the detail is crazy in fact show
me show me have a little zoom in well
they're definitely HD Jesus look at that
so the thing I terrifying hey I mean
terrifying is right but there's
something similar but they're just way
way more intimidating wow this one is
actually an hour like thank you yep
equal parts awful and great so this one
was recommended to us by the way by Korn
spawn yeah thanks you weirdo yeah and
then oh that okay this looks like a gas
mask oh it's kind of like a the fly
thing going on there oh yeah yeah I'm
really seeing that now jeff goldblum go
away don't worry they get worse says pig
head oh god that's hard it is so
surprised he must have been really
surprised when he got his head severed
we made it I end up like this Oh
Oh at least this one's pleasant oh yeah
ditched up face this this reels it back
don't stitch face here wow I have to
even the one thing about this one this
is a weird cross between Terminator and
you know some of the like psychos from
Borderlands yes it is that's a really a
really good observation Hayes Terminator
meets psychos yeah Wow um it's like
Tolly
yes time yeah it's like a yeah
absolutely
maybe Tally's brother yeah yeah I would
say that's ty Lee's brother
yeah okay hanging out get pretty good oh
my word that's just it's not just like
one of those things from resin evil
yeah yeah liquors it's a liquor right
isn't it a liquor face pretty much yep
I'm saying that I'm getting some hands
labyrinth the carnival yeah oh yes the
guy with the eyes in his hands yeah oh
man this is I think the most terrifying
yeah oh and the and I think from the
Lord of the Rings you know the palace
out through the Black Gate basically
everything from my nightmares yeah yeah
that one no this guy's friendly he's
like he's dead but also a walrus but
you're a mammoth the one that this is
taken from also has little tusks so easy
I guess extended that out yeah yeah
that's a really great master looking
like it ah man that is such brilliant
textures as well that's really deep
demonic isn't it this one this is it's
like if somebody came into my store like
looking to buy new weapons and armor
drive-e liners get changed get changed
come back maybe we'll talk business of
course I said this one didn't quite load
the hook properly we got a chance you're
missing there we tried to install a
couple of times and had the same error
maybe there's something we're doing
wrong but em the mask itself is great
though it's the shame that the hood is
all properly well I'll just leave that
I'll just leave that here that we've got
we'll stay here on the screen and in my
dreams for forever and ever if I wait
wait can we can we we way but if we
touch him we touch him does it ask you
my fake get out the way why do you touch
of you closer
pet him pet him said that he won't kill
us
okay everyone time for mod number four
which this week is scorpion race now
we've not got enabled yet but we will we
will in time you just you just want to
see that mask one more it's even better
at night with a torch and ah terrifying
all right let's say let's nude up a
little bit for this one because we're
gonna become a new race oh yeah a little
spawn Specter amazing Wow inexorably
seeking vengeance against those
responsible for the destruction of his
clan and the death of his own family yep
I recognize this a scorpion combat van
noise well is that the best one well I
think that's brilliant well done cept
I've got a point that was all you I wish
I'd lick kill a responsibility no combat
van no it's amazing
here we are stab looking pretty awesome
with our scorpion attire and sword it's
terrifying but he's actually not wearing
anything that's just this skin it's
skinny was even worse came out like that
and God just everything broom been
proportioned it's horrible ah I like
this at all so I've also got some spells
that we can use and I think that Fox is
the perfect unwitting come on I get it I
missed him I missed him ah I'm not sure
about the reason I got him
probably worked I love the voice is
ridiculous oh wow that's pretty dark Wow
look at that audio is well that's just a
classic oh is that is that one taken
from the from the game as in from the
latest Mortal Kombat think so I think so
there's scorpion he famously hates frost
rolls oh yeah well anything to do with
frost
yeah it really pisses him off amazing so
let me get out of there and ah I was
really good
ah what an effective spell oh you'd even
nothing very accurate with it thank ya
haha
those ridiculous spells put him in the
water he's still alive haha oh we got
some texture issues
oh right again I guess you live here now
amongst the purple cube a service not
all come here and chaining and stuff
like that
you can also teleport right so I'm gonna
aim I'm gonna first person that's got to
top that rock we can okay Wow Wow Wirt
oh yes yeah that's gonna get this is a
bit like the the blink spell is that we
had that I guess you gotta get it there
you gotta have a thing
Wow okay hit that tree that's cool
can you can you teleport up the
mountains like what's the range on this
thing are you seeing see a little fire
thing go ahead see that I think that's
what needs to hit see I hit top of rock
okay yeah I fell down it I think we're
the street oh yeah okay you always you
always start on the ground pretty much
butter not bad at all
the other spell we have is a source deal
can I steal the soul of that little
bunny he's running away from us
Oh certainly come back bunny give me
your soul one soul
oh yeah that and sucked is so light and
now he's dead
wow that was kind of I think my kind of
grim might be our absorbed life spell oh
man whole family can't leave orphans
must kill all bunnies feelings are
aching oh you yes right you get in the
weird water wow that's pretty good spell
like that spell but I'm really depressed
now you know I think his soul is gone
except one last thing about this mod if
you do try to put armor on scorpion he
doesn't like it known as such removes
his own head well let's yeah that's how
much he could test his own matter of
justice yeah
nope I refuse I'm taking my own head off
alright time for the final mod of today
which is not the userroutine mode of
course because we've done that once I
said what is our final mod well our
final mod this week is Ken mod lockpick
Pro cheat as recommended by Carmen
Jacobs awesome right so we're in Riften
the moment Eve's guilt cuz we're a
better place to start if we're gonna do
some fevering and breaking-and-entering
stuff like that now this is a bar so I
can't really break in there alright
let's give this a go so as you can see
it added this bar along the top and it
also will tell you the health of your
current block where is the health where
to say that so I think if you start
messing up your you'll start getting
some information so right there you
found the blue is obviously the sweet
spot here and any anywhere where there's
color you'll get a minor amount of
rotation see oh yeah pretty chaotic
health diminishing finishing more
outdoor we're gonna get it and then wow
so it really takes away any challenge
from over NVIDIA hugs I mean as the more
describes itself it is a cheat so you
know this is designed to make this whole
process of lock-picking completely you
know it's no longer a minigame it's just
yeah it's just get it done but I mean
when you when you've been playing the
game for so long I guess you can a guy
get tired of the lock-picking oh yeah it
can be a little bit tiresome and you
know it will speed things up and it
looks also like you still get the the
bonus anyway for successful look picking
I release yeah cheating does pay that's
great it does pay you know we don't have
to do like all immersive mods sometimes
you wanna cheat sometimes you want to
cheat sometimes just want to break into
someone's house on their chair by the
fire and make a terrifying pose exactly
that shadow that is terrifying sab
there's a chicken over here oh yeah yeah
let's let's get this chicken over here
head scorpion loves those guys I missed
well man they just kind of detonate hey
wow that's quite a great way of dating
chickens Oh again
get him aah get over here
oh that's fantastic let's let's bring in
some more chicken yeah more we need more
cheese it cheese it away
and then make them get over here Oh how
would one whoa that's pretty great
wow it's like fireworks the hell was
that noise
all right sad I think it's time to send
scorpion flying up in the air along with
this guard or just he's gonna miss that
chicken no he's not let's bring him in
let's get oh I miss I miss I meant to
get the guard involved but instead wow
we got some good height I'm an arrow
through the heart unfortunately that's
all right you know I'm as let's go let's
do the demonic spawn I think he'll oh
yeah high five yeah he'll use one of his
other hearts yeah oh we're letting the
bad the oh no almost learning about it
gets quite ricochet yeah yeah he's fine
awesome just teleport back up there well
Simon honor of scorpion in this week's
car mods can we get some questions over
here yeah we sent awfully sorry I feel I
feel [__] you should feel bad oh we
could but we can do that don't make me
say guei again all right Kay what's her
first question first question is from
sitter 19 of last week's episode where
we didn't do any question saying did you
guys use Nexus or oblivion mod manager
for the mods on oblivion and why no
mention of more oblivion or sky wind so
so more oblivion will cover this one
first more oblivion is the the mod that
puts morrowind in oblivion right and the
sky wind yeah is the mods that still
impress it in progress sorry yeah that
is a pudding
Morrowind in in Skyrim there we go God
God led the right way around yes and
there's also a sky bolivian as well
which put oblivion in skyrim yeah so
sorry we didn't mention them we we have
actually mention them in the past in a
number yeah we looked into doing one of
them nos yeah they're all in kind of
early then of them were finished yet
their own care beta phase I think Muslim
anyway so it's it's quite quite
difficult it's not a very simple mod to
do so I think when it gets to that stage
we will absolutely jump at the chance to
showcase them I might leave it for a
little while yeah yeah and in answer to
the first part so we use Nexus not
oblivion mod manager as well as well as
some manual installs and of course the
oblivion script extender yellow cam
question number yeah this comes from and
really fast and they asked yeah that
more weighing graphics overhaul made the
game look worse you should have played
without it first if only to see what the
original game looked it yes we should
have that's a very good point also I
think the silver weapons or enchantment
weapons are required against enemies at
normal weapons have no effect against
right yes so what it is like it was an
oblivion where there would be enemies
you do either need magic or silver and
we had neither we had a wooden stick
which we did try and honestly I told a
wooden stick would work I'll be the key
yeah what do you know yeah uh so yeah
apologies that our graphics overhaul
made the graphics it just the landscape
bled yeah and it'll ask you wet to vast
why have you made me work we've had a
lot of practice at the the Skyrim
overhaul we have you know that was all
new to us yeah so our apologies on on
that anyway the last one comes from
Siana rogers who says seven can out of
all the mod type sir quests mb's armors
weapons etc which is your favorite you
know what my favourites was shown in a
long time was today
what was the animation one the one that
anymore that just makes Skyrim more
immersive because it's more believable I
guess I really love those mods so um
yeah that like those animations were
great and it just gave it a whole new
lease of life for me it's the most like
that when we showcase them it makes you
want to just start all over again
re-roll completely new character from
the beginning of the game so they're
probably my favorite overuse em I think
mine I like I love en B's I think they
make the game look gorgeous but I think
mine are I
I think about player homes that the way
people design them and they go to all
this effort of of trying to make them
law friendly or you know use their sort
of architectural minds to work them into
like a cliff face or I don't know I I
think it's really there's a lot of
creativity in there people go to such
lengths to create the perfect home for
themselves that I always loved exploring
the the new homes people make so yeah
player homes for me yeah great well guys
you should answer that question to let
us know in the comments what's your
favorite type of mods um yeah and then
we can also try and showcase more of
them to help out any yes and speaking of
showcasing mods Sabbats time for the
votes so what have we got up for the
book this week okay
up first we have alternate start live
another I have actually used a small
before oh yeah I want to be rolled em
yeah in Skyrim and I used this and this
really cool model I can recommend that
if you've not tried it there we go
alright so we have that next one we have
is a mod that's been created for the
show jessica van nord Wow so how about
that yeah I don't look why not do a
thing with this one but okay yeah so van
you wanna see hey yeah yeah wowie and
then lastly we have Lake View Manor
Preppers peridot respirator wrappers
paradise man we've we've done a we've
done a lake female we have we have it
was heard the look Town Village it was
great yeah so uh yeah that'll be diving
back into Lake View Manor house um but
let us know which one you want as you
want yeah the best way to do that is to
go to tinyurl.com forward slash ready
Sebby blog and every week we update the
blog with a new mod vote link so go
ahead over there let us know and a new
amusing quick if you don't go to see
that then you should definitely go and
have a look said usually right sir a
very very clever heaven rice okay I say
yes re I met Kevin he does he what you
lit literally right he dictates of TJ he
did thanks to me technically my right he
doesn't have any concept of
you know the written language need it
always need it NEP writes with his sword
they yes go there and vote for your
motive choice um if he wants his jest
other why are you laughing at me I'm
laughing cuz it's ridiculous he's also
an artist you know is there anything he
doesn't do with his sword picks his
teeth in the morning does he have seen
him do that
yeah he's a good guy yeah I don't know
why I was seeing you in the morning
he's he's terrifying in the morning and
the evening and the afternoon and where
was I going with this step oh yes such
an get in touch with us and the best way
to do that is on Twitter I'm at Camp
Fras Rob I'm at ready so we go usually
you had no I know I was gonna leave this
bouncy space that's what that's what the
head tilt was for that's your sign to
speak I was looking at the good folks I
was looking at the audience
peripheral vision said anyway anyway so
yeah get in touch let us know what you
think of the show and which module I
guess to showcase and all the good stuff
like that
and we will of course be back after our
wonderful holiday in Ireland next week